welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and as always
with the Super Bowl comes some super
trailers I really need to work on these
puns Disney dropped a big one
and we finally got our first look at the
upcoming series 1 division Loki and
Falcon in the Winter Soldier throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the teasers and giving our thoughts
on what could be happening in the shows
if we're right there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't anything
ruined about the series then I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel for videos
like this every day and I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
the trailer opens with Sam Wilson in
what looks to be a farmer practising
with Captain America shield the
character seems to be a natural with it
and he's spinning it round without
missing a beat it doesn't seem like he's
quite got it pulled together fully yet
though as instead of ricocheting it off
a tree it gets wedged into it and this
is where we get one of the big images
from the trailer that shows it stuck
there now we don't know whose house this
is as it's neither Hawkeye's or Tony
Stark's which are the two big farmland
locations and the MCU so it is likely
that they have a new ally and a laying
low while Sam can build the skills
personally I think this is the residents
that old Steve Rogers used after Peggy
Carter's death and the character didn't
want to bump into his younger self and
affect the timeline so he's just being
well out of the way he could be helping
to train the two and yet that would be
my theory going forward from here we cut
the Falcon soaring through the air and
fighting paratroopers now we don't
really know who these are however it is
clear that Sam has kept the Falcon
identity rather than becoming Captain
America at the end of Avengers endgame
cap & Co was still wanted for breaking
the sokovia accords so I believe they
will still be getting tracked down by
the US government who want to capture
them there's a big signifier later in
the trailer
that the government have put their own
Captain America in place and is likely
that Sam and Bucky are still being
hunted these guys could be Hydra agents
or US spies we don't know yet however
I'm going with the former the shooters
are using the traditional shield skydive
suits but the green and yellow colors
are synonymous with Hydra agents those
who've been watching agents of shield
will know that the shadowy organization
still exists and they pop up from time
to time across all of the seasons the US
also want to set up their own Captain
America which I'll get into in just a
bit so it could be the government and at
the moment a lot of it is up in the air
get it cuz the fighting in the air is
great this channel they do seem
purposely well equipped to deal with Sam
due to the suits so it is likely that
they went after him from here we cut the
Bucky Holdings emo at gunpoint Bucky
obviously has a big vendetta against the
character as he was framed by him during
the events of Civil War not only did
this set up a worldwide manhunt for
Bucky but it also allowed for the
sokovia accords to be set up which meant
that the Avengers were disbanded and cap
and Falcon had to spend a lot of years
in hiding at the end of the film szema
was captured by black panther and sent
to the raft but since then it looks like
he's managed to escape and this may be
because the snap allowed him to due to
society's infrastructure being on the
brink of collapse I mean the authorities
could have could have just let the
criminals out I don't know maybe we
needed an ice cream sellers or something
we do know that Brewer will be wearing
the signature purple mask of the
character but this trailer avoids
showing it Bucky seems to be unwilling
to kill him as he unloads his gun when
it's pointed out the character who knows
he may even become their ally as there's
no reason for Bucky to do this other
than to show he's a better man I mean
this guy pretty much ended up causing
the snap when you think about it he
disbanded the Avengers will never forget
Zemo now towards the end of the trailer
we see you si Jin being paraded about at
the Super Bowl itself I think this is
the Super Bowl I'm not American I don't
know it would make sense you don't come
here for Super Bowl breakdowns do you
I've seen a lot of people say that this
is some finally taking up the Captain
America mantle
however we know from behind the scenes
images that this is actually Wyatt
Russell in the role in case you don't
know in the wake of Captain America's
death the government made their own
appointed Captain America in order to
keep the world at ease and this
character seems to be fitting the mold
of this
he even has samshield so it is likely
that the government did capture the
character take this from him and pass it
on to their new man perhaps this is why
buck he needs emo as if the guy escaped
from the raft then he will likely be
able to break samo prison these are all
just theories at the moment but yeah
that's what I would guess the trailer
actually ends with Falcon and Winter
Soldier shaking hands and it looks like
they formed a strong unit the two don't
have Steve with them at least what we
know about so they will have to form a
strong unit together it's the first
proper big team of two in the MCU and
now both were pretty much sidekicks at
one point
I'm glad we're getting this strong
double team of them both from here we
jump across from Falcon in the Winter
Soldier over to one division we see that
in this reality mission is still alive
and at least this element of the show
will be black and white the series is
going to be setting up several events
that happen in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and according to
the leaks wonder stricken with grief
sets of her own pocket universe in which
she can live out her perfect life this
is how she's able to resurrect vision as
she likely pulled him from another
timeline similar to how Loki ends up
still being alive after the events of
Avengers endgame according to paul
bettany the show is bonkers and it looks
like it's pretty much going to be
similar to a 1950s sitcom at some points
before changing stylistically throughout
the seasons entire run we see snapshots
of this and it looks like the show will
be jumping about through several time
periods after starting at this point
there's going to be the 70s 80s and more
and basically every time period that
your parents say are better than the one
that we live in now vision is also in
his signature gray and know this is due
to the black and white a stake of the
show it's nice that they brought this
across after the character's death and
infinity war in addition to this we also
get a comic book accurate version of
Wonder that suggests she is going into
the comic book lore as well as the
sitcom one Kevin Feige did state that
this would be the show in which we
see wonder become Scarlet Witch and it
looks like this will be the place to do
it we also see Wonder and vision getting
married and it's in their living room
which I guess saves money on the day now
this makes me think that the pocket
dimension will literally only exist in
their home they won't be able to leave
the property due to its size and this is
why the wedding has to be carried out
here it looks like they got it on as
well as they do tease their twins in the
trailer as we see two dummies being spat
out due to the time chimps that we see
they likely won't be babies for very
long
and we probably see them as teenagers
during the show's run this will help
design into the Young Avengers I think
which is rumored to be in development
and the show will have a lot going for
it that pays off in the films when it
releases next up is our first glimpse at
Loki and know it's pretty minor there's
actually a lot to take from it so as we
know an Avengers end game Loki was able
to escape his eventual fate after taking
the tesseract and because of this he's
created a branching timeline that will
have big repercussions this is still a
2012 version of Loki who was a big
villain so this is why he promises to
burn whatever it is to the ground on his
jump suit we can see the letters TBA and
fans of Marvel Comics will know that
this is the time variant authority that
are basically policemen that have been
tasked with protecting the multiverse
from people like Loki who are travelling
through it and wrecking havoc the TBA
have the ability to time travel and we
also have rumors that Loki himself will
be doing this in the show and going to
his big losses and changing them to wins
this could create multiple expansive and
massively warped timelines in which the
character actually rules the universe
I'd love to see this motif pop up
throughout the series
imagine Loki going back to 2012 winning
the Battle of New York and then handing
the tesseract over to Thanos it would be
brilliant to see and a massively hype
for the show and that's all of the first
looks and I have to say I was not
expecting this but I'm so glad we got it
the salmon Bucky plot thread that was
left at the end of Avengers endgame is
probably the one that I'm most
interested in followed by one division
and I call way to see how the world
not having an Ironman our Captain
America the MCU at the moment is in like
a real state of I don't know everything
is up in the air there's no stability
and all of the big names that boss
spider-man are kind of out the window
and know a lot of people are
uninterested because of this personally
I'm actually more invested now because
it could literally go any way
I think this trailer does an awesome job
of setting everything up and I really
can't wait to see what happens when the
shows are finally released I'm gonna be
doing more breakdowns on the series in
the run-up to it so definitely subscribe
to the channel if you want to be kept up
to date with everything
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the trailer and if it's got
you excited for the three seasons
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of the leaked plot of
birds of prey we discuss all of the ins
and outs of the movie so if you want to
know more definitely watch it after this
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below you get
access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made you want to chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people who are
subscribed to the channel and this month
you can win dr. sleep and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you sub with notifications on the
more videos you comment on the more you
have a chance of winning so make sure
you get involved the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of February
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then - ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you